when i talk to elon musk i'm very aware
how dumb i am really yes when i talk to
lex friedman when i talk to him but if
you talk to elon about emotions
if you talk to elon about emotions and
human interaction probably you're much
smarter than him he's not dumb in that
regard he's a different kind of human
man like that's an unusual combination
of characteristics he likes to make
jokes
he takes a picture of bill gates and
then he puts it next to a pregnant man
emoji and it says here's a quick way to
lose your boner
yeah
or if you want to lose your boner really
quick that's what he said he posts that
yeah he he's the richest man in the
world and he's dunking on other
billionaires i love that no you gotta
celebrate that i love you and he loves
that nature of the internet and the
thing that bothers him
is this idea that like one gatekeeper
can dictate whether or not something
gets released into the whole world if
you're using something like twitter like
you could have an amazing story and they
can block it if ideologically they
disagree with it like that's what
happened with that hunter biden laptop
yeah what happened with that
well they decided to say that it was
russian disinformation and that um
you couldn't share the links on twitter
or facebook twitter said that yeah
twitter would not let you share the
links and the link is from a story in
the new york post which is really kind
of crazy because that's like one of the
oldest newspapers in america hamilton
it's a long established newspaper and
they wouldn't let you post it's not like
some
wild ass website right you know some
weird might be a real website
it was [ __ ] new york post and so
when
a
something like a twitter has the ability
to just tell you what you can and can't
talk about yeah even if that thing is
valid even if that thing what if it does
legitimately i don't know what the [ __ ]
is in his laptop but what if it does
legitimately point to corruption are we
supposed to just ignore it because we
want to own the people on the right it's
like that's what we do with pelosi right
what do you mean
corrupt
she's definitely corrupt but she's
corrupt in a loophole way i think talk
to me she's doing a thing where her
husband
buys stock in companies and she may or
may not know things that would have
happened that would affect the way that
company
and they
are so rich they did a thing on her
husband where they showed like uh how
successful he is in the stock market
like compared to regular people right
yeah yeah yeah it's hilarious yeah
and it's like it's totally there's no
way that he knows things she makes like
200
he's better than buffett that's always
100 he's a goddamn wizard
puts a wizard's hat on and he finds the
right things to gamble on yeah and he
always wins i mean she's worth like
hundreds of millions of dollars yeah
good for her does she come from under
again i don't think so i think i respect
that though because most of these
[ __ ] come from money they keep
changing the rules of the game to help
themselves at least if you were in the
gutter before and then you shift the
rules up it's like well at least you
made the climb
a lot of these [ __ ] are just
born in it
ah you're saying that she hustled for it
yeah at least she got there on her own
hey what is it about people that were
born in it right like uh princes and
why do so many of them become like
psychopaths i don't think throughout
history wait a minute what do you mean
you say first generation becomes
psychopathic a lot of like like sodom
hussein's sons were some of the most
evil people that have ever lived they
would do horrific [ __ ] there's stories
of them kidnapping women on their
wedding day like going to them taking
them from their husband raping them and
feeding them to their dogs
yes like for real yes pink finish yes
that's all that's left
to their dogs yeah i think there's a
sociopathy that develops or sociopathy
ever you say it when you're so removed
from any normal human interaction that
it you're not you don't like ever
develop you don't get to feel bad for
people because no one shows you the bad
[ __ ] so there's no remorse to feel i
think so you're just like well let's
just push this as far as i can push it
this is the theory i just came up with
[Laughter]
i think they get stuck in this idea like
we have a human beings have this thing
where we other each other you know like
if if you're gonna go to war with that
group even it's like north versus south
america we can we can other each other
yeah and i think we could do that with
anything yeah i didn't know that
happened with the kids i thought the
kids ended up kind of weak no i heard
they were awful but
not saddam's kids i'm just saying in
general i thought like the the kids are
successful people as well sometimes but
there's there's a few of those instances
of evil kings right that's like game of
thrones remember john freeman
he was an evil king like there's a long
history okay of young men who take over
the throne from their father and they're
just [ __ ] evil yeah well maybe they
don't have the empathy because they
didn't have to earn it like if you come
from nothing you have empathy for all
the other people who have nothing and
those kids who come from everything why
would they even feel bad also
the reality that just the reality of
violence was accelerated back then
because people were doing sword fighting
yeah you know they were hitting each
other with bows and arrows and hacking
each other to death and so it was
happening and probably like everybody
saw it right like the amount of laws and
rules that they had back when that [ __ ]
was going on yeah you used to see death
all the time yeah i think about that now
i i've seen a dead body like three times
in my life yeah so if you yeah i mean
like my grandfather passed away open
casket like that kind of thing but like
back in the day they all saw bodies yeah
like you're confronted by life and death
bookended all the time guys that clip
was brought to you by blue chew best
boners in the business same active
ingredients as cialis or viagra but this
is the true the only one we rock with
get yours for free at bluetooth.com
promo code andrew all you gotta do is
pay five dollar shipping